les élus de la réunion et de mayotte ont
inauguré officiellement la délégation de
mayotte
installé à saint denis un bâtiment tout
juste rénové qui servira de relais
administratifs entre les deux
départements pour les mâts aurait
installé à la réunion de manière à ce
que pour qu'on puisse rendre plus
visible et plus présente
mayotte à la réunion offrir plus
d'opportunités et de meilleur service à
rendre à à notre communauté ici et en
même temps à permettre une meilleure
connaissance de mayotte et des mahorais
ici à la réunion
ce nouveau service départementale de
mayotte est un espace d'accueil
d'orientation et d'insertion pour les
mahorais présent la réunion une
structure qui vise également à
développer la coopération régionale dans
la zone océan indien
nous sommes tous français
un des îles de l'océan indien nous avons
un destin en commun et le destin en
commun fait que nous avons nous
retrouver à partager des moments de
dialogue de convivialité et aussi parce
que nous avons nous avons une belle
espérance nos populations surtout les
jeunes
cette inauguration s'inscrit dans la
continuité de la signature de la
déclaration d'intention portant sur la
création de la plate forme de
coopération de la france de l'océan
indien
l'objectif étant de renforcer la
coordination des actions menées par les
territoires français de l'océan indien
dans le domaine de la coopération
régionale
[Musique]